our second talk on the applications is
by dice tyson and well
i'm very curious what kind of impact
you're going to make with
duct tape i see you have a nice hack to
planet shirt
might be relevant okay do you have your
screen to share or
no i don't have any slides so
you have to have to watch my face for
the whole time
if that's okay perfectly find my meat
and i'll stop my video and i'll give the
floor to you
i'm curious to hear what you will do
with duct tape
all right well first of all thank you uh
for having me at this
at this conference it's the first time
for me uh presenting in such a way
uh it's a it's a it's uh taking a bit of
getting used to
but uh but it's fine all right
houston we've got a problem
these are the famous words spoken by
john one of the astronauts
in the apollo 13 mission
they were in space obviously because
they're astronauts
and they were on a mission
to the moon
during this mission a lot of things went
wrong
they john spoke these famous words after
they heard an explosion
in the in the spacecraft what had
happened
is that one of the liquid oxygen tanks
had exploded and now was
leaking their precious uh contents into
space
and liquid oxygen is one of the most
precious
uh substances they they have it's
provided their
their fuel the air they breathe so it
was really important
so they had a big big problem basically
they were shipwrecked
in outer space can you imagine how that
feels
so what they did is they they had
two choices basically they could either
turn the
spacecraft around and fly back to earth
or they could fly around the moon
and since they were already almost
halfway to the moon
they did they were afraid to turn around
the spacecraft
and fly back to earth although that was
the quickest route
because then they would have to ignite
their main engine
and because of the explosion they were
afraid that
uh turning on the main engine would yeah
cause even more damage so they decided
to
fly around the moon and then catapult
back to
earth basically so that's the the path
they chose
obviously they were not gonna land on
the moon again anymore
so that was off the table they were just
only interested in getting home safely
at some point in this journey a warning
light
came on and this warning light
told them that the co2 levels inside the
spacecraft
were getting dangerously
and this was a huge problem because
they basically shut down all the systems
inside the spacecraft to
conserve their fuel and oxygen
it was freezing in there
and they had little oxygen left
and this was a big problem they were in
the lunar module the lunar lander that
would
take them to the moon they were they
used the lunar module as a kind of a
lifeboat so to say to bring them home
but this lunar module was only equipped
to provide oxygen for two people for two
days
and the trip back around the moon was
four days for three people so obviously
this was not going to work
and they needed to fix this problem
they called up houston and together with
engineers on the ground
they tried to solve this problem because
they did have
plenty of co2 scrubbers inside the
spacecraft
from the surface module of the
spacecraft
but they they were the lunar module
and the co2 scrubbers there were
round and the co2 scrubbers from the
surface module
were square and they needed to fix this
can you imagine going through years of
training
an education to become an astronaut
being in space
and then be confronted with your
childhood frustrations
trying to fit a square peg into a round
hole
anyway together with people on the
ground they managed to fix it
they used parts of their space suit
they used the cover of the flight manual
and
they used the role of duct tape and
together with all these materials
they made a kind of adapter to fit the
square
module into the round hole and this
pragmatic solution basically saved their
lives
well now you might think why is this guy
talking about uh space
uh and all astronauts is he does he want
to become an astronaut is he an
astronaut no that's not the case
just think that this is a very nice
example
of how you can use
the things that you have readily
available
with some creativity and some duct tape
to create
real nice solutions for problems that
you have that might save your life
even so it's real macgyver to the max
i'm not sure
how many of the attendees of this
conference know who macgyver is but
if you do you know what i'm talking
about
all right so cool i'm dice
i'm an engineer basically i'm a
i've been writing code for 20 years
and at some point in time
i began to wonder
how many how many lives
did i change with my code how much of
the
the lines of code that i wrote actually
did something in the wild and
and reached another human being and
helped him
so this is something i i came up with
and it kind of became an obsession
and since that time this has been
my main driver my motivation to do my
work as an engineer
i want to help people use technology
the right way and because i think
technology is a
means to an end it's not the goal in
itself
so i always try to to look at problems
and see how can we use technology in a
pragmatic way
that really solves this uh this issue
for people
i work at q42 q32 is a digital agency
we have offices in the hague and in
amsterdam and we make all sign
all kinds of stuff websites apps you
name it
and inside q42
i and a colleague are running a
department called
hack the planet like it says on my shirt
and at hack the planet we get to spend
our time
to use our technical skills to make the
world a better place
so we get to use the knowledge we
gain in also commercial doing commercial
projects and we apply this knowledge
to uh global challenges basically
and i'm really really happy and
honored basically that i can do this
i think i have the best job in the world
anyway how did we start so
the whole idea of hack the planet
started with talking to greenpeace
we were talking to them and
there was a huge problem and this
problem was in sumata
in indonesia huge forest fires going on
there
and even more so they these forest fires
are still going on and this is a huge
problem not only because
forests are being burnt down but
thousands of people
are killed because of these forest fires
or because of
all the smoke and stuff
animals are losing their homes or
getting killed in the fire
it's a huge problem and it's mainly
caused by the palm oil industry
greenpeace was there on the ground to
document what was going on
and to help troops on the ground fight
these fires
and we were talking to to them and
greenpeace
uh they bought a drone which is kind of
a reasonable thing to do because you
want to
monitor these forest fires and you
basically want eyes in the sky
so that's what they did they bought a
military-grade drone
that could fly autonomously and capture
images from the sky
but i'm not sure how many of you have
been flying with the drone but
usually what happens when you fly a
drone at some point in time
you crash the thing and that's what
happened to greenpeace as well
so at some point in time they crashed it
and
this was really downer for them because
this drone have cost them 50
000 euros and when we heard this story
we thought
wow uh isn't there another way so what
we did basically is we went to the
hobby shop we bought just an
off-the-shelf drone
we took a raspberry pi a bit of duct
tape
we put it on the on the on the
plane put some open source flight
controller software on there
and we basically created an autonomous
flying drone that could be
stay in the air for an hour and had all
kinds of sensors
for around two one or two hundred euros
so that was really amazing that we were
able to basically
glue together and use some duct tape and
macgyvering
to basically create what they wanted
for a fraction of the price and that's
when we thought well when
if we can do this what else can we do
and that was basically how hacker planet
was born and how we now
try to use technology in all kinds of
areas different areas
i'm going to talk about a couple of
different projects one of the other
projects we have been working on
was called meet the soldier and it takes
place in uganda
in uganda there were three two rivaling
tribes
so uh these tribes were really living
in a primitive way and
they were in conflict with each other
for generations
and at some point in time we thought
what would happen
if we could like teleport these tribe
leaders
of these tribes and put them into each
other's shoes
well this is not very easy but we
thought
what happens if we use virtual reality
for that so that's what we did
we shot videos in these villages
of the tribe leaders they put on a vr
headset they've never seen this
kind of technology before and suddenly
they're in the village of their enemy
this was an amazing experience for them
and
they experienced how the the village of
their enemy what it looked like
and uh what their daily
doings were and they also learned what
impact
the the raids had on their lives because
people were getting killed they learned
that they both lost the brother
in these fights and because of this
project
they came to realize that they were not
so different
and they actually became friends with
each other and there is now peace in
that region
that's i think an amazing example of uh
what technology can do
if you apply it creatively so that's
really awesome project
at the end of the session i will by the
way share some links in the discord
channel for this talk so you can
basically check out the various projects
the project i'm working on right now is
in a different area it's in the area of
wildlife conservation
and this is also a huge problem like 80
percent
of all the elephants have gone extinct
have died basically um
and zambia was the country that had the
most rhinos in the world
and can you guess how many rhinos there
are left in zambia
there are zero left and this is really
sad
it's not only sad for the animals
themselves
but it causes various problems it causes
problems to nature because elephants and
rhinos
they used to spread seeds so areas are
really drying up there
because these these animals are not
spreading these seeds anymore and
the wildlife
[Music]
like the wildlife criminals so to say
it's it's a really organized crime they
they poach animals and they ship it to
to other countries
it's basically spreading diseases as you
probably know
uh diseases like sars but also like the
corona virus
has been spread through wildlife markets
so this is
also a really big problem
anyhow we were
talking to in this case wwf and we were
talking to some rangers that were
actually protecting these parts
and we were chatting with them and again
i'm not a wildlife expert so i don't
know much about poaching
i'm a nerd like i said i know how to
write code
but we were talking to them and this is
what we usually do we talk to them and
we try to spot opportunities how we can
use technology to solve their problem or
or make their life their lives a bit
better and
we were talking to these rangers and
they told us that
they recently apprehended two poachers
so they apprehended two poachers and
they told us well they always have two
things with them
they always have a gun obviously
and you don't want to be uh if you're a
poacher you should
you need some kind of weapon and they
always have a phone
with them and that was really
interesting
these poachers use their phones for
communication
because if you have coaching elephant or
if you have poacher rhino it's not
something you can just
carry on your back so they need to to
arrange some kind of pickup
and they're just people like you and me
they use their phone for navigation
and for leisure they're sometimes in
these parks for multiple days
and they get bored
so they're probably playing candy crush
or something like that
long story short we learned that these
poachers
carry phones with them and we thought
okay what can we do
to try and detect these phones because
if we can find the phone
we can find the poacher that's blue to
it
and that's what we've been doing we're
right now developing a system
that is able to detect gsm signals
in the wild and
using rolling out like a grid of these
sensors
we can also triangulate kind of their
position
and we can help rangers that are
protecting these parks
protecting these animals help them
better
focus their efforts on the ground
because these rangers
usually are small teams couple of
rangers maybe 10
that have to protect huge areas
these areas sometimes are as big as the
netherlands and belgium
altogether so these are really huge
areas so if you can provide them with
some information that they know well
there are some suspicious activity
in this sector then this is really
helpful
to them so we're developing the gsm
sensor right now
but it does it detects the cell phone
activity
and then it uh communicates over laura
laura
for for those of you who don't know what
it is some kind of
long distance messaging protocol so they
communicate over laura
and then we alert the rangers they have
a dashboard
and they can use it to track down
vouchers
we are going hopefully if all goes right
of course
going to zambia november to roll out the
first version of this system
and yeah this is really important moment
for the for us because then we learn
uh yeah if it's valuable to the rangers
because that's
where why we're doing it
while doing this project we came across
something else these rangers usually use
camera traps camera traps are
cameras they attach to trees for example
and they have a motion sensor and when
an animal of a human
or a human passes by then it takes a
picture
but these camera traps have sd cards so
as a ranger i have to go and collect
these sd cards
every couple of weeks and then i have to
put them in my
into my computer and then i can go
through tens of thousands of images
and then i can see well there was an
elephant here three weeks
ago and there was a human a poacher here
four weeks ago
and we thought well that's kind of a
hassle and what good is this information
when it's
overdue for for four weeks so again
we thought what can we do in this area
that's a project i'm working on right
now
and we are now trying to build a smart
camera trap
so we're developing an a module
basically
that can uh tap into the sd card of the
camera trap
and use machine learning to classify the
images
and then send a signal
to the cloud saying well there's an
elephant on this picture or there's a
human
in on this picture it's a really
interesting
project i'm working on for this project
we're not using
laura we're using this thing i'm not i
think
you you guys can see it it's a rock
block
and um it communicates over uh the
iridium satellite
so we send these messages over satellite
um and we're only sending the
classification results
and i have all kinds of stuff here i've
uh well raspberry pi and some coral
hardware because we need to do some
machine learning
it's really interesting um
but this is really a challenge right now
a funny thing by the way
um
[Music]
unit testing is kind of a different
subject than this talk
but i i want to go briefly go into it
like unit testing is i don't know about
you guys but
it's usually kind of
the last thing you do in a project maybe
there are some
guys out there that really are doing
this test different development
but i can tell you if your software is
going to be deployed
in the wild where there's no internet
connection no way for you
to know whether things are going right
or not
i've been writing the code for this
system in python
and um i think it's the it's the project
that has the most test coverage i
ever created so this is really
really cool i'm really kind of scared to
deploy the software i
want to know that it works so i really
went overboard on unit testing on this
project
all right back to the camera trap so one
of the the things we're still struggling
with is
we have trained a machine learning model
model but
it's a bit heavy so it doesn't perform
really well on the raspberry pi
so we're now in the process of finding
other architectures or other
platforms to basically train this
machine learning model
so it runs fast enough on a raspberry pi
maybe using coral hardware it's a
hardware from uh from google to
accelerate tensorflow models
so i just want to do a call out if you
have any ideas on
making like a machine learning model for
the edge
and you have any thoughts on this please
contact me and i'm
happy to hear your thoughts that's what
we're working on
right now the biggest challenge
basically because this thing
has to be battery powered maybe we're
probably gonna attach a solar panel but
it has to be really low
low power all right
i've talked about a couple of projects
we are doing
and uh i want to leave it at that
concluding i think in my opinion there
are three ways
ways you can make impact you can
help a lot of people a little bit
that's you can pray make a pretty pretty
big impact if you help
a lot of people a little bit you can
help
very few people a lot
and you can do nothing sadly the last
the latter is something that i often see
is that people are really
like angry about uh wasting food or
air pollution and then they're not doing
doing anything about it
and i have found that it's really
rewarding
if you do projects that help few people
a lot so for instance to meet the
soldier we only
made peace in in two tribes not world
peace
but you can really see the result and
that's really fulfilling
and now i basically want you to think
about something
what's the thing that you're really
struggling with that you're angry about
what's the challenge
you think that needs to be solved
so i just want you to take a few seconds
and think about this what do you think
that needs to be changed in this world
and put this
idea in your head just now
i hope you all have some kind of idea
and i hope you're already working on it
but if not
then why not and i want to challenge you
to think how you can use your unique
skill set
and take on this problem think of ways
how you can use your skill set
to tackle this problem contact parties
that can help you or reach out to me
maybe
we can share thoughts so that's what i
want to give you
thank you very much for listening to me
and
i'm gonna i have a couple of minutes
left left so i'm gonna
see if i have some questions
uh let me see
oh the only chat i have q a
image classification done on software or
hardware
well that's an excellent question maybe
i've already answered it
the classification model we have right
now it's it's a
a model trained in fastai which is a
really really great platform
using pytorch but
like i said it's a bit heavy and it's
really accurate on detecting humans
it's more than 95 accurate in detecting
humans and detecting elephants that's
the
the most interesting part for us
but it takes a really long time on the
raspberry pi 4.
so we're now considering if we should
retrain the model in tensorflow lite for
example
because tensorflow lite is a lot faster
and if you use tensorflow
flow light you can use basically the
coral hardware to
accelerate it or we're thinking about
maybe using a simpler architecture for
machine learning model or
using quantization techniques
um so that's
that's about it i guess like i said
before i will share some links and info
in discord if you have any questions
there i will take a look and
thanks a lot for listening